the family of a georgia woman missing
since 2005
is waiting for a state supreme court
ruling that would allow a long-awaited
murder trial to go forward
after tara grinstead disappeared her
case remained unsolved for nearly 12
years
but authorities may have missed leads
that potentially could have solved the
case
soon after she vanished peter van sant
reports for this week's 48 hours
from the day tara grinstead disappeared
from her home in 2005
the small town of ocilla georgia has
been consumed with one question
what really happened to tara grinstead
neighbor
janice polk tara grinstad was a
very well liked high school teacher tara
also competed in beauty pageants
later mentoring other young women that's
what she was doing on the morning of
october 22nd
2005 the day she disappeared
recalls her best friend maria woods
harbor
and after the pageant she went to a
cookout went home
and then nobody's seen her since
for years the case remained a mystery
but this man john mccullough says that
back in 2007
he tried to share with authorities
information that he believed
could have solved the case he says a
buddy he met in the army
named bo dukes told him he knew who
killed tara
he had told me that his friend
accidentally strangled her
and he needed help getting rid of the
body so you called the police department
this is john mccullough i know who
killed tara grinstead
does anyone call you back no but a
decade later
this woman brook sheridan came forward
with a similar story
also from beau dukes then her boyfriend
beau told her his friend ryan duke had
murdered tara
during a robbery the two men had similar
names
but were not related he said i can't
handle it anymore and he starts telling
me everything
beau told brook that he had nothing to
do with tara's death
but had helped his friend ryan burn
tara's body
in a pecan orchard i said you need to
confess
you need to own up to what you've done
and confess based on what beau told
investigators
ryan duke was arrested for grinstead's
murder
he pleaded not guilty and is awaiting
trial
in march 2019 beau dukes was convicted
on charges relating
to covering up the crime and sentenced
to 25 years in prison
but tara's friend maria believes that
the whole truth
hasn't been told i believe
that ryan and bo duke were both in this
together
peter van sant joins us now good morning
what a story how are you this morning
i'm good i'm good i'm alive so i'm good
amen so tell us what is ryan duke side
of the story
well ryan's story has evolved back in
2017
according to the georgia bureau of
investigation he allegedly
confessed to killing tara he said he was
high on drugs when he entered her home
to steal her purse but now his defense
attorneys have publicly said that that
confession
is false and at trial they plan on
pointing the finger of blame at beau
dukes
even though there is no physical
evidence that beau committed the murder
and that latex glove that was found on
terrace property
has ryan's dna inside it
so with all the tips that came in after
her death what happened to them
this is so frustrating you heard john
mccullough uh
he's he's just tormented by this well it
turns out several weeks after tara's
disappearance there was a second tipster
who overheard
bo and ryan talk about the crime
implicating
themselves so he also contacted
authorities
but sadly no one properly followed up
on these tips in a case that could have
been solved
in a matter of weeks instead of many
years
peter van san thank you so much you can
see peter's report that tara grinstead
mystery on 48 hours
this saturday at 10 9 central right here
on cbs